knowing who to take counsel from and who
nacho very critical let me explain
everybody is gonna give you advice
everybody so for for example we started
going through a phase which it was like
so we want to do a meaning and you guys
give your advice on how we can make the
company better because this is out of an
article we read it's so nice because
it's great when everybody gives feedback
give us your feedback on what you think
so all of a sudden this feedback I think
we're doing this wrong I think we're
doing that wrong I think we're doing
this wrong and in all of a sudden I'm
sitting there saying terrible idea who
are you to tell us we're doing these
things wrong and I realized credibility
is what's predicated based on your
advice being heard you can put a lot of
advice you want by the way
again what I'm saying a lot of people
are not gonna agree with because if you
go read Huffington Post if you go read
Fortune magazine or money magazine
written by these journalists they say
things like you have to be willing to
want to hear everybody wrong if you want
to build a big organization because you
could be taking advice from somebody
that's never made more than forty five
thousand dollars a year telling you how
you're doing ten different things wrong
and then you sitting there saying what
am I doing this here for this makes no
sense to me you can't lose your core so
I started looking who has given the
advice what is the credibility what is
the expertise what is the background how
long have you been here to know the
culture to know what we stand for to
know the history of it then I'm willing
to take counsel from you there's a lot
of consultants when you start a business
then you become a CEO you pay me $20,000
I'll be able to fix your problems for
you ma'am if you're so good at solving
my problems for me you would never be a
consultant you go run a company and be a
CEO if you're such an expert you become
a concern in the first place you know a
lot of times people become consultants
because they could have make in the
world of business running a business is
not easy
all of these coaches I'm a life coach
I'm doing all this other stuff if you're
so incredible at being a life coach why
don't you go build a company and have a
couple hundred employees and sell it for
a couple billion dollars but that's not
what I like to do no because you know
it's hard there's a big difference
between talking about all these cultural
articles nineteen points where people
don't love each other and have autonomy
and all these other things nice great
sweet looks
very good in a utopian world where
unicorns fly when you're running the
business there's a completely different
ballgame you have to understand who to
take advice from and who not to take
advice from based on where they're at
again not a lot of people going to agree
with this but I'm giving you those
mistakes I made and you can do whatever
you want to do with them
you